you guys do some serious serious
fighting in this I feel that we
rehearsed our fight forever yes so that
was probably mostly because of me
because my first go-around yeah what I
hadn't realized and I realize just in
the doing of it is you'll work on a
sequence for weeks and if you're like me
look nervous about it and we want to do
such good job and then you're with
someone who's really seasoned and you
realize that it all changes in the day
anyways and so what you want to do is
work as hard as you can but have
flexibility and have some dexterity and
be ready to throw stuff away and do
something new and on the spot which he's
revenge's revenge
you mean the whole film oh yeah I think
that's tyke as a real strength as he can
take a scene understand the structure of
the scene of where the scene fits into
the structure of the film and then play
with it and play with the dialogue and
come up with fresh things and there's
something about the way he improvises
that he encourages that very present
tense very spontaneous invention for you
to I mean this is a movie about the
destruction that of Asgard but both of
your characters have very complicated
relationships with Asgard hmm that is
true that's true yeah I think they both
feel like then they initially looked
there perhaps they had no place in house
guard there was no allotted role that
they should play in the regime but turns
out well I went spoiler
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]